hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to a story about my uncle
now this game was made by the developer
of goat simulator of all games but this
one is not as silly it may not even be
any silly at all but he asked me to give
it a try he gave me a key for it and
goat simulator was super duper fun and I
want to see what he can make it's time
for bed honey
dad I can't sleep okay tell me a bedtime
story all right what do you want to hear
something something about an adventure
hmm I think I know just the thing
When I was your age my biggest dream was
to follow my Uncle Fred on one of his
adventures around the world one day he
disappeared
oh hello I stepped into the lobby of my
uncle's house oh cool just across the
hill from where I lived with my mother
aha her mother she had tried to keep me
from going but I wanted to see huh Fred
was home yet from his latest adventure
right okay whoa glowy glowy map I think
I need to touch that my uncle used to
send me postcards from his long journey
uh-huh exact Nepal Galapagos Kilimanjaro
the Amazon River aha this was the first
time he had left without a word weirded
out sending cards huh strange maybe he
didn't go anywhere on this world now you
may be thinking that this game is kind
of like gone home or dear Esther and
that is just walk around and explore but
I know for a fact that it is not you
will see what I'm talking about in just
a little bit whoa Louie Louie house
countless of times countless of time
Locker
which usually was closed I found
something I hadn't seen before
uh-huh and then I distracted on shoot
whoa assemble to one that Fred used but
smaller in size for me curiosity got the
better Oh
tried it on galue eagle oh is it like it
had been custom-made for me wait a most
mysterious room of my uncle's house aha
Observatory yeah
there he kept his newest experiments yes
now
it held a pad used for disposing of
garbage um oh I touch anything
sorry officer I'll put my head in my
head I'll take the suit off oh boy I
seem to be being sprayed with some sort
of substance am I gonna get launched in
it's okay I can't move and I about to
get launched into space here because I
don't think I'm suited for space travel
or maybe I am suited for straight though
okay off we go then
whoa I'm trying I'm a story about my
uncle Wow oh sorry maybe that was
preemptive excitement there hello
loading screen now this is what I was
talking about when I said that it's not
necessarily what you may have been
assuming it's just the beginning of the
game no but thanks to the suit I wasn't
hurt uh-huh I had no idea where the pad
had taken me um back then yeah I didn't
care so much about where I was going
yeah all right then how I would get home
yeah because I'm kind of a kid or
something whee I can I already figured
that out game now this is where the game
get interesting I haven't played it
before but I have seen a bit of it okay
no never mind I was just lying that's
now it all falls on the ground but not
in water okay I couldn't swim with this
thing on
huh best be careful I will try my best
walking so okay Wow shaky-shaky
oh well what did I do
why did I jump super high I held down my
right mouse button oh okay how do i oh I
get it okay I get it I get it I get it
here we go here we go whoosh oh I didn't
sprint I'm still gonna make it ah got it
nailed it okay oh I thought that was
something important ah yep okay so this
game is a lot about movement oh I
learned a secret but I'm learning a lot
before I actually need to get to the
point where I needed I'm telling you I
swear I have not played this game before
for me someone had built these britches
ah ha ha these symbols your uncle where
were they
yeah oh cool yeah
far out it's kind of like a gears edge
if you guys ever played that it's a
really cool game measuring tool that
Fred was the milk
yes exactly he done measuring though so
I drew the results to give the Fred okay
thank you
at least you are a diligent all god I'm
dying Oh Fred Oh Fred couldn't see me I
did not do that well well I think it was
about time that mark was about to get
bad through this game so everybody
everybody place your bets or collect
your winnings for cuz you all knew that
it was coming I was gonna be bad
eventually hey update I just did not
need to sprint there but anyway this
game is a lot about moving so I'm gonna
give it a very good try here so that you
guys can really get a see of it just
even take a good look at it get an idea
whether this game is worth it to you
that is what is important here this game
obviously put a lot of work into it and
uh ah oh god I thought I was not gonna
make that oh I love it
oh hello glowing Chloe mmm well I found
a small campsite yes where Fred must
have slept before going further Oh
uh I knew was him yeah because the place
was littered with empty packages of his
favorite hiking fruits Wow
can't Supes tube food and instant
noodles yeah
that sounds gross is it scrumptious it's
not that bad
scrimp what you seeis Uncle Fred and I
went hiking into the mountains and we
were surprised by a blizzard when I
snuck in a small cabin free oh god damn
it I'm dying again was too food and cold
captain's court can gosh gross uh-huh we
oh yes
oh god I love it it's so Mirror's Edge s
but somehow even more elegant don't you
don't you don't you don't you oh god I
thought that was gonna move away from me
all right so I just got time that's
right yeah
oh god oh god oh god where am I going
where am I going okay I'm alive I'm
alive I'm alive
look I really thought I was gonna die
there whoa
well something tells me this kid
shouldn't have had a suit well what is
this whoa ah yeah I love it too much the
blue will light up when you're in range
of the blue ha no okay the blue light up
when I oh when I'm arranging a blue
awesome awesome awesome love it love it
awesome device left this sort of symbol
everywhere I grab uh-huh I noticed
similar symbols already there in the
cake oh okay I get it
wait certain that this place was where
Fred had gone yeah I gotta find Uncle
Fred whoop it up oh god I hit the rock
Fred help a friend
Wow then release it soon enough
huh yes now I'm getting it guys I'm
getting good at this game yeah I know
you guys had full faith in me that I was
gonna happen to miss that I'm gonna miss
that oh no I'm not oh no I'm not oh god
I thought I couldn't land on nothingness
but I'm making it scrap a douches okay
gotta go Oh ooh
well where's the Sam ball thought I can
grapple when I was doing it oh there yep
I didn't think I could grapple when I
was jumping here yeah it's very pretty
very well made in this I think it's made
on the Unreal development kit if ñam ñam
mistaken suit was fantastic yes it is
finding a power leap with a grapple I
could fly long distances through the air
great speed ah yeah Oh God okay okay
aah panicked too much here I just need
to go with the flow man I just need to
go with the flow
oh this was a mistake a know-nothing
this up about to die Wow save me Thank
You Fred I don't know if how supposed to
be here but here I am I love it I love
it too much okay where am I going with
this
all right then I guess I'll go over here
oh okay that shadow scared me for a
second but thank you for not killing me
I'm actually doing pretty good why is
there a symbol light up over here okay
why all right whatever don't question it
just jump gonna make it gonna make it
gonna make it I don't even know if I'm
still going the right way how the world
did his Uncle Fred develop anything like
this oh I see moving target aah come
back here you douche Oh
Oh God I did something wrong I'm dead
thanks Fred
your nephew is dead up okay where am I
going i'ma goin where am I going
oh there we go oh god I love it I love
you know there really hasn't been
another movement-based game besides me
reg I'm getting a little too excited
because I meant this to be a more talked
you I didn't charge up huh
thank you he did that I didn't charge up
but I meant this to be a more a low-key
talking one I didn't expel okay all
right okay okay I didn't expect to be
yeah okay all right that's cool - thank
you
Thanks okay wrong way but yeah that's
all right
it's okay it's all right I understand
I'm gonna get you maybe I could just
maybe I could just sprint jump to over
there and I be able to GI be able to get
this one just like this just like that I
beat your game you rogue wait Oh
alrighty then
Pope yeah thank you that how much funds
get oh okay you're gonna give it to me
all right
take me where I need to go I'm much too
tired but seriously how did his Uncle
Fred develop all this amazing technology
except that while he was exploring he
found aliens and I'm gonna make it he
found aliens and he was just able to
reverse-engineer their technology I
don't know huh Oh so every time I grab a
lawn it's gonna permanently leave a mark
weird and how did the uncle not die that
is definitely an important question and
why are there things floating I found a
second Oh awesome
I don't even know why I needed that but
whoosh okay neither that need it uh now
okay still alive oh this is too cool Wow
and where in the world would these caves
be unless on an alien planet and how in
the world how even would this even work
oh man sooo cool - cool - qaul yeah sooo
cool bruh so cool
clock sooo cool come here you might give
me a second hoosh tangly
hey great I bet I could get up there
somehow yeah
alright alright it's like zero-point
energy from The Incredibles hmm come on
make it make it baby thank you and jumpy
and Ronnie seems like this story ended a
bit okay on my own not on my own anyway
secret place Oh che for someone oh come
back come back I need you I need you I
didn't decide fast enough never mind I'm
dead
thank you no you come back here you
[ __ ] I'm gonna get you this time don't
you think you can run away from me oh
thank you I need to go over there you
were of great help to me and my amazing
grappling abilities I'm like Cirque de
Soleil all on my own I should open a
one-man show Cirque du Soleil with is
come over here thank you please please
and thank you god this is so cool okay I
haven't even talked much about the
design of the game am i I've said that
it's pretty but anyone could say that
it's pretty it flows really well it
flows almost as well as Mirror's Edge
did and it's hating except I can't see
my legs or anything it's not parkour
based but it's like a different
principle kind of oh god I visit this
game that I want to say that it relates
to you but I can't remember what it is
ah alright death is an acceptable
outcome from that you come back here
whoosh thank you lift me up higher there
we go okay I can't remember what type of
game it's actually from like something
with a grappling mechanic I want to say
it was a 2d platformer but I can't
remember I mean old grappling mechanic
is not unfamiliar but it's completely
different to see it uh displayed in a 3d
game okay come here come here come here
come here come here I need you don't
drop me down thank you
um God why can't I remember right in the
comments below if you remember a game
based on grappling mechanics a I know
there's many I got dings damn damn damn
how the hell isn't supposed to make that
I don't have three power cords unless
you were supposed to give me another or
I missed you somewhere help thank you
for not being there I got this one it's
okay I didn't need that other one I got
this one maybe it was a bit of a red
herring deal for that first one anyway
thank you thank you thank you please
don't kill me kill me kill me don't kill
me thank you
all right boo party lights is there a
party in my honor is my uncle gonna meet
me there is this where everyone gets
happy is this way alien world lights did
Fred put them here uh-huh where was
somebody else here as well for the party
that's gonna be thrown in my own oh oh
oh let's go see what's in the party hey
everybody
Marga Blair's here you want to say hi to
me anybody don't see what I want to be
much celebrating maybe from the movie
avatar on Pandora it's like that I need
to talk to a hoie I need to plug my
tentacles into something on the ground
oh wow I knew it was aliens it had to be
aliens good oh hello
who are you I don't know who are you
you're not from here anything's are
laughing in the wrong place you look
just like Fred Fred that's smaller okay
less hair on your face right
she knew Fred hey I grogger that he was
my uncle and that I was looking for him
did he know me boy uncle I don't know I
said that he was that I had known him
all my life
okay weird really me too
I'll help you find him wait you know Oh
Madelyn the others call me mad Maddy
okay times
I don't know why really but you can call
me Maddy okay mad Maddy you've never
been to the village right let's meet
over there in the square are they okay
with me I bet you can get there easily
with your suit thing yeah yeah I guess
so I'll see you there
okay how are you gonna okay advantag
round village inhabited by frog people
that was a good description more like
salamanders ah
either way they walk like humans they
talk like humans that was impossible do
they expect me to have three cuz I do
not have three yet thank you very much
yeah Boop Dee that didn't hurt God who
is his Fred guy how did he know that
girl his whole life or her whole life
okay so I need the super jump now to
sprint come on come on come on come on
no no no no no no I look bad for the
whole internet it whoa okay is that lady
okay with me just falling and dying in
the world or that girl god I don't even
know why is this okay where did all
these people come from no idea it was
weird it's weird but so cool I know that
this guy's his name's Armen he's been
working on this a while obviously hello
did someone just say hey to me this
guy's obviously been working on this
game for a long long time and it's real
ow okay I don't know why Town Square
yeah and that over there is Fred's tent
okay see him in a few days though uh-huh
maybe our elder Samuel knows where he is
why do you have glasses lot stuff broken
glasses sleep boring stuff if you asked
me but it's worth a try okay for asking
him though you should check out the
village it's not so bad unless you have
to stay for too long
uh-huh go to the island with the
windmill and you'll see Samuel scope
from there cool I'll go on ahead and
tell him that you're coming is not much
versa price
later later SIA blue here all Adeline
and agreed to meet her later
cool it's strange huh how could I talk
to someone who was not even human
I don't know still feel like it was
perfectly normal cuz I don't know dad I
don't know why but I expected because
I've been playing too many horror games
I expected this town to be totally
abandoned enough to go very wrong but it
kind of didn't either way I'm actually
all out of time for this playthrough I
just wanted to give you guys a first
look because the developer asked me to
play his games check it out so he gave
me a lot of stuff to putting goat
simulator and actually there's been a
recent patch for the beta for version
1.1 of goat similar and I'm actually
gonna do video that but either way if
you think this game is really cool you
can check it out I'm not sure if it's on
sale right now if it is there will be a
link in the description below but let me
know what you could think of this game
in the comments below leave a like if
you enjoyed this video and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
thanks for watching
there's something ok this